let's move on to Wall Street everyone's
favorite Street am i right oh my lord
guess what their salaries are going up
and quite substantially wall street
bonuses I've got numbers here people uh
they rose eight percent to 20 billion
dollars this is the same wall street of
course that we bailed out and continue
to bail out and you know they just keep
getting bigger and bigger but we keep
giving more money you guys have any idea
what the average wall street person
makes per year I saw your notes for the
show and I remember thinking that is
astronomical we have much higher than I
thought yeah three hundred and sixty-two
thousand dollars is the average salary
on Wall Street they're given themselves
uh this bump in the bonuses nice guy
around by the way I didn't even mean to
do that there themselves a bump and a
bump in the salary and uh what what do
we do like a we is there anything we can
do to stop this and says gonna say marry
them David let's get married to them
I'll pretty much are you dating a Wall
Street pants no I worked on Wall Street
um this is a pause for last moment
clearly as a legal secretary for four
years and we were on wall street except
I would show up in like thrift store but
not like the cool rap song kind like
really ugly [ __ ] Oh what can I curse you
can say that guy they look great this is
young there's no I know that they have a
type and it's not me two of them saying
so it's me maybe more like this I don't
know what you're implying about my
journal like that I haven't worn in like
eight years we do nothing what do we do
we so we just can't they just hold us
hostage yeah I feel like we've been
hearing about this every year and they
keep going up they keep going up I don't
think there is anything we can do I
think it were powerless for whatever
reason yeah i mean at their eat cake
though interest in it literally is
getting to that point mrs. what occupy
wall street was fighting against yeah
nothing they had no effect don't know
what the salaries are not in the park
yeah no we think that obama is sort of
on our side with this but this is all
still happening under his watch you know
it means so she wait should we it's a
Jedi mind-meld oh oh yeah that's the my
mouth that's the mind meld the mind
trick would have been like you won't
take your bonus Oh
they would have been nice they went with
the bonuses and so there's nothing we
can do we just got to put our hands
alone if I really know what I've never
got to go to sell it I've never get
really I don't think so no one what's
like five hundred dollars and they're
like ran to like TJ maxx and bought 50
pairs to capri pants I got a starbucks
card one time and I felt like that was a
bonus that's a very nice one actually
yeah yeah actually you know right now if
you go to starbucks that come they'll
put five extra bucks on your starbucks
card what that's a little bonus for you
guys out checking yeah if you have a
sarma card we've got only one more
segment and they don't get on starbucks
calm and get five bucks bonobos calm is
the official outfitter of the Ruben
report enter code Ruben report for
twenty percent off your next purchase